words matter they can heal and they can
kill yet they have a limit when I was in
eighth grade my teacher gave me a
vocabulary sheet with a word genocide I
hated it the word genocide is clinical /
general bloodless dehumanizing no word
can describe what this does to a nation
you need to know in this kind of war
[Music]
husband's killed wives wives kill
husbands neighbors and friends kill each
other someone in power says those over
there they don't belong they're not
human and people believe it
I don't want words to describe this kind
of behavior
I want word to stop it but where are the
words to stop this and how do we find
the words but I believe truly we have to
keep trying
I was born in Kigali Rwanda I felt loved
by my entire family and my neighbors I
was constantly being teased by everybody
especially my two older siblings when I
lost my front tooth my brother looked at
me and said oh it has happened to you
too and will never grow back I enjoy
playing everywhere especially my
mother's garden and my neighbours I
loved my kindergarten we sing songs we
played everywhere and ate lunch I had a
childhood that I would wish for anyone
but when I was six the adult and my
family began to speak in whispers and
shush to me anytime I asked question one
night my mom and dad came they had this
strange look when they woke us they sent
my oldest sister Claire and I to our
grandparents hoping whatever was
happening will blow away soon we had to
escape from there too we had we crawled
we sometimes ran sometimes I heard
laughter and then screaming and crying
and the noise that I had never heard you
see I did not know what those noise were
they were neither human and they also
the same time they were human I saw
people who are not breathing I thought
they were asleep I still didn't
understand what death was or killing in
itself when it was stopped to rest for a
little bit or search for food I will
close my eyes hoping when I open them
I'll be awake
I had a no idea which direction was home
days were for hiding and night for
walking you go from a person who's away
from home to a person with no home the
place that is supposed to want you has
pushed you out and no one takes you in
you are unwanted by anyone you are a
refugee from age six to twelve I lived
in seven different countries moving from
one refugee camp to another hoping will
be wanted my older sister Claire she
became a young mother
and a master by getting things done when
I was 12 I came to America with Claire
and her family on refugee status and
that's only the beginning because even
though I was 12 years old sometimes I
felt like three years old and sometimes
50 years old my past receded grew
jumbled distorted everything was too
much and nothing time seemed like pages
torn out her book and scattered
everywhere this still happens to me
standing right here after I got to
America
Claire and I did not talk about our past
in 2006 after 12 years being separate
away from my family and then seven years
knowing that they were dead and it's
them thinking that we were dead we are
reunited in the most dramatic American
way possible live on a television on The
Oprah Show
I told you I told you but after this
show as I spend time with my mom and dad
and my little sister and my two new
siblings that I never met I felt anger I
felt every deep pain in me and I know
that there's absolutely nothing nothing
that could restore the time we lost with
each other and the relationship we've
had soon my parents moved to the United
States but like Claire they don't talk
about our past they live in a
never-ending present now asking too many
questions
not allowing themselves to feel moving
in small steps
none of us of course can make sense what
happened to us though my family is alive
yes we were broken and yes we are numb
anywhere silenced by our own experience
it's not just my family Rwanda it's not
the only country where people have
turned on each other and murder each
other the entire human race
in many ways it's like my family not
dead yes
broken numb and silenced by the violence
of the world that has taken over you see
the chaos of the violence continue
inside in the words we use and the
stories we create every single day but
also on the labels that we impose on
ourselves and each other
once we call someone other less than one
of them
or better then believe me under the
right condition it's a short path to
more destruction more chaos and more
noise that we will not understand words
will never be enough to quantify and
qualify the many magnitude of a human
cause destruction in order for us to
stop the violence that goes on in the
world I hope at least I beg you to pause
let's ask ourselves who are we without
words who are we without labels who are
we in our breath who are
in our heart beat
[Applause]
[Music]